okay that took a
really long time i thought it was going
to take like an hour
no that took like seven hours or so it
took a really long time
cursed the uh single threaded nature of
python
uh coming over here um just in case
uh at least so i forgot already anyway
so for everybody watching this video
it was probably back to back so i guess
you guys are not forgetting
but starting funds we said was a hundred
thousand waiter size is a hundred
so we're trading with basically
a one thousandth of our total
um purse size so that's pretty small but
again like i said i believe the
um the best amount to trade with would
be like one over like one point six
like one 1.6 millionth so you'd want to
like
show up to the casino casino with 1.6
million and be prepared to play
i don't know like a million a million
wagers so
this certainly is not a get rich quick
scheme by any by any means
but it is profitable and at least you
can kind of have fun gambling with
fairly good chances or fairly good odds
um
if you're wagering a small enough
portion of your entire fund so anyways
we had a hundred thousand waiter size
of a hundred and the thing that took the
absolute longest is we allowed for up to
a hundred thousand
wagers um so before we were allowing for
a hundred wagers or a thousand wagers
and the problem here is as you make more
money
it becomes harder and harder to go broke
so long as you're making more money and
you've
won enough in a row to where your bet is
at least somewhat low
so you know you might make a lot of
money but your current wager size might
be
you know you start at 100 but your
waiter size is 5 000
okay but once you work your way back
down to a
you know wager size of somewhere in the
hundreds again
you've kind of all locked in your
profits so to speak
after you've made so many wins in a row
that you got back down to a waiter size
in the hundreds so
it would be wise to continue playing but
we needed to set some limit on wager
count otherwise over a long period of
time and we wouldn't either
go broke or it would never stop so we
had to put a limit on wager count but i
wanted it to be large enough to run
through a lot of options
so we set a hundred thousand
scrolling down um i'm trying to see how
many did we
set um
right so we let one million people
uh sample this so we tried this across a
sample size of a million
different bettors with different odds
and all of that
and anyway at the end of the day we see
that ignore this if you were from the
last video i believe this was just
something we ran
in the last video so that's just here uh
i was expecting this to take a lot less
time than it did
otherwise i would have gotten rid of
that too but anyway this is our actual
result
uh from those settings so from allowing
up to a hundred thousand wagers to take
place
a million different bettors and
one one thousandth of a bet size we can
see that even though that's the case
our bust rate is still pretty high
that's 97.58 percent
um people go bust
and only 2.4 of the people make a profit
well those people that make a profit
this is how much profit we made but as
you can see it's actually not that great
of a uh
of a profit so like this is gosh i don't
even know what this number is
but the difference is eight six five
let's see if i can't break this down
right the difference here is 865 000
and so this is 865 000 this
is i'm sorry this is
this is 865 um
million and this is
let's see we've got thousands
million so this is 100 billion and this
is 865
million um so we're approaching
almost a one percent profit now
again though this just kind of brings
home the point that okay we approached a
literally a one percent profit
uh that's definitely uh not exciting at
all most of the time people go to gamble
for
you know some excitement um so
yeah so anyway i just wanted to show you
guys
uh these odds when we wrap up i'll kind
of talk a little bit more about my
thoughts
on all these gambling strategies and
stuff
but um moving back to our tutorial here
even though um we found you know these
numbers here we did this strategy
and at the end of the day we still
we just kind of arbitrarily picked
um the wager size starting funds
and wager count right we just kind of
randomly picked that stuff and as i said
in the beginning
the wager size and starting funds are
going to be tied to each other because
really what this boils down to is a
percentage of your purse
so there's no reason to very like to
make both of these
a random variable at least i don't i
don't foresee any reason
if you happen to think of why that would
matter feel free to comment below but as
far as my logic and reasoning goes
there's no point because we're really
looking for a percentage size of your
your
full trade amount plus
the wager count that you would maybe
want to go through with
so it might be wise to only play this
strategy over 100 wagers
and then restart again stuff like that
so uh what i want to do now
is allow for some of these things to
actually change and we want to make
these kind of variable
so what we're going to do is we're going
to utilize the monte carlo
simulator to simulate the outcome
of just changing up these variables
randomly kind of like we did with the
random multiplier
and so we're going to do that and see if
we can come up with any other variables
that are superior to the ones that we've
been trading
and this will be kind of even though we
did it once with a monte carlo generator
we actually i mean like we got a result
and it was like 1.7 i think was the
the best multiple but that was only one
variable
and so that's not as impressive as
coming up with say two variables or
three variables so what i want to do is
just kind of show you guys how you might
at least do multiple variables and then
we'll even do maybe a third variable
and then finally at the end of the day
all this is nice when you print out
numbers but everybody wants to look at a
pretty chart
and so i'm going to show you guys at
least with two variables and we'll
probably do a three-dimensional charting
as well
of uh what our monte carlo simulator
shows us and gives us out of our data
so that'll be lots of fun so anyways uh
this video no new coding just the
results here
um and what we plan to do in the next
video
uh so anyways as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until
next time